out there welcome welcome welcome into
another edition we are doing it again
the live stream for the wall street
journal i am dion robowen this is market
takes you may notice it looks a little
different in here if you've tuned in
before
i am in my boss's office actually we are
back in the office here at the wall
street journal so i'm in my boss charles
farrell's office uh he's off this week
so he's letting me use it
so appreciate you guys being with me uh
right here in the boss's office for
another edition of market takes uh
listen we are diving all the way into
today's non-farm payrolls report the
august jobs report um and we are going
to be looking at everything in that
report what it means for the markets
what it means to the economy uh what it
means for the jobs outlook as we move
forward uh through this year we are now
into september getting into the end of
the third quarter moving into that very
important fourth quarter so this report
is going to tell us a lot about the
september
fed meeting and what we can expect from
fed chair jerome powell and all that so
look let's get into the report today
we're going to be talking about the
headline number on that report
what that tells us as well as how the
report stacked up to expectations uh you
know our dow jones economist survey came
in pretty close to what the actual
number was uh we're also going to talk
about how this fits in with recent data
and the picture that we've gotten from
other reports that we've seen on
inflation on growth uh other measures of
labor market that we got uh earlier this
week and last week um and we are also
going to talk about how this um you know
it could really move the market and some
other issues uh within the the labor
market and within the jobs market and of
course we're going to talk about the
effect on the stock market bond market
commodities dollar crypto all of that
good stuff
and of course what it does and what it
says for the economy so without further
ado let's get into it today we saw in
august the u.s economy had 315 000 jobs
the unemployment rate moved up just a
little bit to 3.7 from that 3.5 number
we are still near those 50-year lows uh
in terms of the unemployment rate so
still strong still continued growth in
hiring um and all those things
before we get too far into the report
though let's take a look at the market
right now we are seeing stocks moving
broadly higher although the nasdaq now
flat and moving into just a little bit
negative we've seen stocks come off
their highs the day when the market
first opened at 9 30 eastern time you
saw stocks kind of picking up moving
higher we were about a half percent on
the s p 500 the s p
now down just about 0.2 percent the dow
right around there as well but the
nasdaq is flat to a little bit negative
on the day and we have seen that kind of
consistent move downward from the stock
market uh stocks really liking the
initial
reaction to the job report but as we dig
through it we're kind of finding some
things that maybe stock investors are
not so excited about i'm going to tell
you what a few of those are after we dig
through the market of course the bond
market very important in the reaction
that we're seeing there we're seeing the
one year the one-year treasury bill
really jumping all over the place it was
down about 10 basis points then it was
up about 10 basis points right now the
one-year bill down about 22 basis points
so in terms of the yield so you're
seeing a lot of bond buying right now
folks especially in those shorter dated
bonds doing a lot of buying which means
they're expecting for the fed to maybe
do less as yields go higher that means
expectations for inflation are higher
we're seeing especially in those shorter
dated a six month one year two year and
three year all the way up to the five
year a lot of buying but the most
significant buying in that two-year
level which is the most correlated with
expectations for the federal reserve to
take action we're seeing those yields
come down significantly a lot of bond
buying which means likely investors are
expecting to see the federal reserve
kind of pump the brakes on what they've
been doing raise rates may be a little
less than expected not just at this
meeting coming up in september but
remember we've got fed meetings in
november and december as well
as we look out into the currency markets
that's probably where we're seeing the
most significant movement uh you've got
the euro up about half a percent right
now on the dollar um and that's really i
think we're seeing the most movement in
the market uh expectations for eurozone
inflation have been coming in hot and
expectations for the european central
bank to take more action and further
action on raising rates have been coming
in so that's definitely something to
watch for this likely report or it seems
like at least the market is saying we
think the federal reserve is going to do
less throughout the rest of the year we
think the european central bank has more
to do so those rate differentials
between the dollar and the euro starting
to come down a little bit right now and
that's what we're seeing in the data as
we look at crypto you're seeing bitcoin
up almost one percent ethereum up almost
three percent ether really seems to be
moving on the expectations for that
ethereum merge that we've got coming up
uh market seems to be pretty excited
about that we've seen it pretty broad
growth in ether uh over the past couple
weeks as more folks expecting that merge
to come in as we look at commodities
you're seeing crude oil jump in about
two percent today gold is up almost one
percent silver up a little more than one
percent natural gas way down down almost
four percent so you know a bit of a
mixed bag but overall you're seeing
prices rise in commodities so let's get
back to that jobs report and why
the the report might have been moving
the markets in all those different ways
we came in a little bit over
expectations in terms of if you're
looking at the factset numbers or broad
set of economists they had expected 300
000 jobs to be added our dow jones
survey of economists actually predicted
318 000 jobs so coming in almost right
on the screws there we got that 315 000
number today there were expectations for
half or i'm sorry jobs more than 500 000
jobs were at it last month for the month
of july we got that report
and so this is a slow down from that
july report
also very significant because we saw
revisions for june and july of 107
thousand almost all of that revision was
in june 105 000 less jobs added in june
after this revision so you saw that pace
revised down from 398 000 in june to 293
000. now june becomes the lowest uh jobs
number we've seen since april of 2021
this month what we saw in august was the
second lowest jobs added since april of
2021 so almost a year and a half since
we've seen a report this low and seen
this few number of jobs added
that means we're seeing a decline or a
slowdown in the pace of jobs added
that's exactly what the federal reserve
wants to see and that's why you're
seeing those bond yields come down
that's why you're also starting to see
fed fund futures prices the market is
showing that it expects the fed is more
likely to raise rates by 50 basis points
or twice the normal pace than 75 basis
points or three times the normal pace
you're seeing those expectations being
being uh
extrapolated into the markets fed fund
futures and the bond market showing
expectations for less action from the
federal reserve or a a smaller rate
increase at this month and throughout
the year in november and in december um
so digging into that report again you
saw we saw according to the household
survey now the jobs report is two
services the household survey and the
establishment survey all that means is
that the folks at bls the bureau of
labor statistics they call people at
their house they say hey are you working
do you have a job are you getting paid
they also send a survey out to employers
how many people did you have working for
you we're seeing a bit of divergence in
those two surveys in this month now the
household survey when they called folks
up and asked do you have a job how's it
going that showed that 786 000 people
returned to the labor force last month
now that's a big part of why we're
seeing that unemployment rate increase
because more people are coming into the
labor force more people are coming into
the market looking for jobs um and
applying for jobs not all of them are
finding jobs but we are seeing more
people moving into labor force and
that's a good thing the labor force
participation rate still is is lower
it's about one percent lower than it was
in february of 2020 before the coven
pandemic really started to take hold but
we are still seeing we're seeing an
increase now in that labor force
participation that we hadn't seen in a
while it picked up 0.3 which sounds
small but that's actually pretty
significant when it comes to this metric
which really doesn't move around a ton
and that one percent drop-off is
actually pretty significant as well
because again this is a number that
doesn't move around a lot historically
it's been about 62 to 66 67. um we are
down if you take out the pandemic we're
still at low at the lowest levels we've
seen since the late 1970s so keep that
in mind when you're looking at these
numbers in terms of labor force
participation
however this month a good number and it
shows that more people are moving back
into the labor force and that's why you
saw the unemployment rate pick up that's
a good thing for the economy it could be
a good thing or a not so good thing for
the market we are going to see
um we are saying like i said though if
you look at two of the last three months
have been the lowest we've seen this
year for the entire year and going all
the way back to april 2021 you are
seeing a slowdown in the pace of hiring
you are seeing a significant slowdown
and that could mean the federal reserve
has less work to do that could also mean
employers are starting to get a little
worried and starting to you know maybe
pull back on hiring maybe start to say
okay well you know we had plans to hire
a hundred people now maybe we only want
to hire 50 or maybe we want to put that
on pause for a while if you've got folks
out there and there's still a lot of
folks who are hurting who need work who
aren't able to find that work that's not
so great for them so keep that in mind
as we move forward
wages continue to rise but we are still
seeing a kind of stagnation around this
five percent level um average hourly
earnings increased 0.3 for the month 5.2
from a year ago but again still that was
below estimates and we're still not even
close to the eight and a half percent
rate of inflation overall in the economy
that we saw from the cpi so again
increases in wages but not enough to
keep up with overall inflation and not
showing signs that it's going to catch
up that's a good thing for the fed
not such a great thing if you're a u.s
job seeker if you're someone looking for
work
and we could start see
a pattern where you know it's
data is good news for the stock market
good news for investors but not so great
news for the economy not such great news
for folks who want to see a strong u.s
labor force and that's something to
watch out for as we look through these
releases in coming months
be sure that you're you know right here
with us here on market tanks as you are
right now i appreciate you doing that
we'll be talking through this and other
reports going forward i want to take a
step back again and look at some other
recent data we've gotten the adp private
payrolls report that came out on
wednesday came in well below
expectations 132 000 jobs added wages in
that survey rose by seven and a half
percent or seven point six percent to be
exact that showed a much larger pickup
than we've seen from the government's
data now traders and investors much more
likely to look at that government data
over the adp data but that is something
to watch out for there's a very
interesting quote from adp chief
economist neela richardson uh she said
quote our data suggests a shift towards
a more conservative pace of hiring
possibly as companies try to decipher
the economy's conflicting signals
we could be at an inflection point from
supercharged job gains to something more
normal that's exactly what the federal
reserve wants to see and again it could
be a strong sign now on the other side
of that we also got the jolts report job
openings and labor turnover survey uh
that showed
11.2 million job openings more than or
almost double the number of unemployed
workers that showed about 5.6 million
unemployed workers so almost two job
openings for every single unemployed
worker out there that shows there's a
lot more room for growth in terms of
wages in terms of jobs all those things
that was a worrying signal but today's
jobs report i think puts a lot of that
worry at least kicks the can down the
road a little bit says okay you're not
seeing turbocharged hiring you're not
seeing turbocharged wages you are seeing
a
a moderating level of growth in the jobs
market that's good if you want the fed
to calm down not continue to raise rates
at a very high pace the challenger job
cuts report we saw earlier this month
also showed a continued cooldown 20
cuts in in august that's down from july
a slow down again in terms of job cuts
so less people getting laid off is good
but an increase over the same period in
august 2021 so
less jobs cut than the month before but
more jobs cut than the year before shows
you that again we're at that kind of
moderate pace things are moderating a
bit
it's unlikely to get the fed to
reconsider their overall plan to move
forward with rate hikes but this report
looks like it could be enough to get the
fed to say okay we don't need to do 75
basis point rate hike at this meeting
let's do 50. let's step back let's see
how things are going and maybe
throughout the year the fed can also say
okay maybe we don't need to do 50 again
in november maybe we can do 25 basis
points the rate that rates had increased
in years prior
at that 25 basis points per meeting
level so we could even be going back to
that if job increases in the job and
labor markets stay on the trajectory
that they're currently on definitely
keep your eye on that
look the big picture from this report is
right now investors in the market are
saying you know what this isn't a big
deal we don't love this we don't hate
this this might get the fed to calm down
this might get the share jerome powell
after that tongue lashing he gave us at
the jackson hole meeting to step back
and say all right we don't need to go as
fast on these rate hikes as we thought
the economy seems to be cooling a bit
let's wait and see and not do quite as
much
it's not too hot not too cold this jobs
report seems just right the good thing
is that it wasn't anything that's going
to create a lot of confusion uncertainty
among investors the bad thing is you
could really interpret this report a lot
of ways so stay tuned for what's going
to come from markets i think investors
will have a lot to dig through i think
you're going to see a lot of folks
really spending a lot of time with this
report parsing through the details
getting all the little pieces of the
report and then making decisions on what
this says about the economy going
forward because right now it doesn't
look like things have changed all that
much
um listen we are going to be doing this
again i think the next big report that's
going to come out the big report that
could change the dynamic in the market
that could change the trajectory or
where things are going the cpi consumer
price index report that's coming out on
september 13th that's a tuesday morning
we will be right here on market takes
hopefully my boss charles farrell lets
me use his office again i don't know if
he will he might tell me i got to go
somewhere else but we'll be here live on
youtube streaming giving you the
breakdown of the data and what that
means for markets in the economy as we
move forward so please join us then i'm
deon rabone reporter with the wall
street journal i look forward to seeing
you at our next report on cpi